Traduttore: Marco Caresia
Revisore: Andrea Giglio
[A.H.] Mi chiamo Armin Holzer,
ho 28 anni e vengo da Sesto Pusteria,
sono altoatesino e,
vivendo nelle Dolomiti,
ho avuto la fortuna di scoprire
la passione per la montagna.
Già da piccolo e grazie
anche ai miei genitori
che mi hanno portato in montagna,
ho imparato tante diverse
discipline sportive
e una di queste è la slackline.
Vivere in montagna mi ha fatto scoprire
le montagne ma anche lo spazio areale.
Questa è una slackline che, come vedete,
unisce da sinistra a destra
e io la metto su in alta montagna
e cammino da una cima all’altra.
Camminare su questo filo
mi fa sentire libero,
mi unisce con la natura,
e adesso camminando qua sopra
può sembrare uno sport individuale,
sembra che io sia qua da solo,
ma dietro a tutto questo c’è sempre
un grande team, ci sono amici.
E questa fettuccia rossa semplice
non funge solo come ponte tra montagne
ma anche ponte tra culture e mentalità,
e personaggi diversi.
Ecco perché vi presento
il mio amico Alessandro D’Emilia,
con il quale ho fatto
tantissime cose insieme.
(Applausi)
[A.DE.] Buongiorno. Buongiorno a tutti.
Io mi chiamo Alessandro e anch'io
ho avuto la fortuna, come Armin,
di vivere fin da piccolo in montagna:
a Misurina nel cuore delle Dolomiti.
E questa vita passata in montagna,
ogni giorno ti porta a vedere
lo stesso panorama
con occhi sempre diversi.
La prima volta che ho conosciuto Armin
è stato circa cinque anni fa:
eravamo proprio vicino a una
di quelle montagne che tutti conosciamo,
le Tre Cime, e là sotto c'è un rifugio.
Ci siamo incontrati.
L'ho visto con uno zaino
che era quasi il doppio di lui
e gli ho chiesto cosa era andato a fare.
Lui mi ha risposto:
“Sono andato a fare highline!”
E io gli ho subito detto:
“Cosa, highline?”
Non avevo mai sentito prima questa parola.
Occhio, stai attento che qua ti fai male!
[A.H.] Sono davanti alle persone.
Non è come in montagna… Sono un po’ teso!
[A.DE.] Da quel giorno ci siamo conosciuti
e insieme siamo andati ad esplorare
le cime di quelle montagne,
ma non più solo con le scarpette
da arrampicata o con gli sci,
ma portandoci dietro questa fettuccia
che ci ha unito,
che ci ha fatto conoscere piano piano.
Una di queste traversata, la prima,
è stata sulla Cima Grande di Lavaredo:
quel giorno siamo partiti presto,
siamo arrivati in cima,
abbiamo montato tutto e siamo riusciti
a camminare già nello stesso giorno.
Ma quello che posso dire è
che questa slackline ci ha insegnato
che anche nella vita di ogni giorno,
vale la pena di vivere appieno,
ogni momento in cui ci troviamo.
Proprio da quel momento ho iniziato
anche a dormire sulle cime delle montagne,
perché quando si arrampica, o si scia,
si pensa di andare su veloci
e scendere veloci.
Questa slackline invece ci ha portato
a rilassarci sulle cime delle montagne,
a passeggiare, a goderci il panorama
da un punto di vista
più esclusivo e particolare.
Quella mattina alle Tre Cime ci siamo svegliati
vedendo una di quelle albe
che potremo ricordarci per tutta la vita.
Ci siamo svegliati ed eravamo
sopra il mare di nuvole,
come spesso accade in montagna.
Un'esperienza che ci è rimasta
impressa nel cuore
e ci ha portato poi
a guardare verso altri orizzonti.
[A.H.] Esatto.
Quella mattina, che mi ero svegliato
qualche oretta prima di te,
ero là a testa in giù, guardavo fuori
e mi sono riaddormentato subito.
Pensavo di sognare: alla fine era vero
che eravamo lassù, ed è stato bellissimo.
Ricordando il detto
di Walter Bonatti che diceva:
“Chi più alto sale, più lontano vede”.
per noi è stato un po'...
[A.DE.] Ispiratorio.
[A.H.] Sì, un po’ un'ispirazione
per provare nuove cose.
Ad un certo punto mi ha invitato
Massimo Braconi,
un grande mio amico di Belluno,
a partecipare ad una spedizione in Cina,
per scalare con gli sci il Muztagh Ata,
che è una delle montagne
più alte del Pamir, in Cina,
e io dopo qualche pensiero,
dopo qualche giornata di calcoli,
anche come soldi, perché costa andare là.
[A.DE.] Eravamo giovani,
non lavoravamo ancora tanto.
[A.H.] Eh già! Gli ho detto subito di sì.
Gli ho detto:
“Ma perchè portiamo solo gli sci?
Portiamo anche la slackline,
proviamo a fare una cosa nuova”.
Ero curioso di provare a camminare
sospeso in aria sottile,
che nessuno l’aveva mai provato prima.
E così subito ho proposto questo progetto
ad Ale, e anche lui ha detto subito di sì.
Arrivati in Cina ci siamo subito resi
conto che camminare in aria sottile
non è come camminare al mare, diciamo.
Cambia tutto, tutto quanto,
dentro di te, cambia la mente.
Sì, anche il tuo modo di reagire
a quello che succede.
Ogni cosa.
Perché, per fortuna, quando siamo arrivati
là al campo base, che si trovava
a circa 4.000 metri di altezza,
abbiamo trovato un lago vicino al campo
che ci ha permesso di allenarci
su questa altezza.
Visto che per noi era
la prima volta in aria sottile,
ci dava un po' di sicurezza.
Noi non sapevamo come il corpo
avrebbe reagito,
come ci saremmo acclimatati,
avevamo paura.
Dicevi: “Devo bere di più, c’è pericolo
di star male, male di montagna”.
Questa slackline, ci ha fatto
acclimatare al meglio,
perché è una cosa che conosciamo bene,
ci dava molta fiducia
e anche tranquillità.
Mentre scalavamo la montagna,
che per scalare queste montagne alte
si deve andare su e giù,
su e giù per acclimatarsi,
ad un certo punto abbiamo trovato
sui 5.000 metri di altezza,
un punto perfetto per tirare un highline
e così ci siamo dedicati
a realizzare questo progetto,
perché eravamo molto curiosi di vedere
cosa succede quando si cammina
sospesi a 5.000 metri.
All’inizio della traversata, sai,
hai paura, è tutto strano.
Ero seduto su questa fettuccia,
mi giravo indietro e dicevo:
“Speriamo che tengano le soste”.
Anche se sai che è tutto sicuro,
è tutto doppio.
Ma anche là, devo dire che,
senza l'aiuto di Ale,
non sarebbe mai stato possibile
fare una cosa del genere.
Sono arrivato da una parte,
ho attraversato dall'altra
e sono arrivato che, sì,
mi sembrava un’utopia.
Mi sembrava di essere sveglio in un sogno,
ed era una sensazione abbastanza forte,
e dopo, quando era partito lui,
magari spiega un attimo,
di come è partito,
di quando avevi in testa quel mantra.
[A.DE.] Certo,
il discorso iniziale di Armin,
che la slackline può sembrare
uno sport individuale,
ma in realtà c'è un team e un'amicizia
che si basa principalmente sulla fiducia,
perché a volte non c'è
neanche il tempo di parlare.
Si parte e si decide: uno va da una parte,
uno dall’altra,
si mette in tensione la fettuccia,
ci si assicura che tutto va bene.
Perché con l'allenamento,
hai la certezza di poterti fidare
del tuo partner, del tuo amico.
Ma a volte non non basta
anche questa motivazione
che viene dall’esterno,
ma bisogna ricercarla in noi stessi.
Ognuno di noi cerca a suo modo,
a seconda di quello che gli piace fare,
di quello che gli suggerisce il momento.
In quel momento,
io mi ricordo perfettamente,
che così dal nulla mi è venuta
una frase in testa
e che non sono riuscito più a togliermela
per tutta la camminata.
E questa frase era:
la passione nel cuore libera la mente,
la mente libera la passione nel cuore.
Ad un certo punto,
realizzando questa cosa,
non riuscivo più a smettere mai
di dirla perchè ho trovato subito
una connessione tra quello che proviamo,
quello che desideriamo,
veramente e sinceramente, ogni desiderio
che però richiede anche la consapevolezza
e la volontà di crederci fino in fondo,
se no non si potrà mai realizzare.
Di farlo nel momento e nel posto.
E che non basta avere un'idea,
ma poi anche il processo
che ti porta a realizzarla,
quella è la cosa
che ti arricchisce di più.
Questa giornata, possiamo dire,
si è conclusa con questo scenario
incredibile sopra le lingue ghiacciate
del Muztagh Ata.
[A.H.] Eravamo lì alla sosta, rilassati.
[A.DE.] Ad un certo punto
si è alzata in volo
una piccola aquila
che girava sopra di noi.
[A.H.] Era enorme,
non era piccola, l’aquila!
(Risate)
[A.DE] Capisci subito di essere proprio
nel posto giusto al momento giusto,
e questo ti dà la forza di andare avanti,
di credere in quello che fai
e di pensare sempre a nuovi progetti,
a nuovi sogni da realizzare
con le persone e con i tuoi amici.
Ma purtroppo, come tutte le cose belle,
i sogni, a un certo punto,
bisogna risvegliarsi e tornare a casa.
E in quel momento,
quando siamo tornati a casa a Misurina,
quello scenario che ci sembrava
ormai tutto esplorato,
che sentivamo come casa,
l'abbiamo riguardato,
e ovviamente avevamo altre esperienze
che ce l'hanno fatto vivere
con nuove emozioni nel cuore
e altri orizzonti da poter scoprire.
E proprio sul Monte Piana,
una montagna vicino alle Tre Cime,
un pomeriggio, siamo saliti con gli sci
e le pelli di foca
a fare una gita alpinistica.
Ci siamo accorti che questa montagna
era un posto magnifico.
[A.H.] Era un altopiano con delle gole
dove su si può tirare con dei canali
centinaia di fettucce diverse.
[A.DE.] Ed era proprio dietro casa.
Come dire ritornando da quest'esperienza
abbiamo trovato di nuovo la possibilità
di poterci allenare e di poter usufruire
al meglio di quello che avevamo,
proprio dietro casa, senza dover fare
migliaia di chilometri
per avere delle motivazioni
in cui credere.
E questo ci ha portato subito
ad un altro pensiero:
che quel posto era così bello
che non potevamo tenercelo solo per noi
e fare slackline, per quanto ci stiamo
simpatici anche sempre e solo in due.
Abbiamo iniziato a invitare degli amici,
anche loro sono rimasti entusiasti,
e ormai da quattro o cinque anni
- sì quest'anno sarà il quinto anno -
è cresciuta una specie di comunità
che ogni anno si riunisce
in questo meeting di highliner
e di atleti da tutto il mondo:
più di 25 nazionalità diverse,
e quest'anno eravamo più di 350.
Su questa montagna,
che la maggior parte della gente
conosce per la sua tragica storia
perché era la linea delle Tre Cime,
e comunque delle Dolomiti,
era la linea di confine,
proprio cent'anni fa
durante la Prima Guerra Mondiale.
Quindi per noi questo era da subito
un punto molto importante
che ci ha fatto riflettere quando eravamo
su sospesi a camminare su questa montagna.
Il fatto di poter condividere di nuovo,
di avere la fortuna di vivere questo posto
in compagnia di altri giovani
da tutto il mondo,
era veramente la realizzazione
di un sogno ancora più grande,
che non era un record
o una cosa personale,
ma la possibilità di poter condividere
quelle emozioni che erano partite
da una piccola culla
e poi si sono evolute nel tempo.
[A.H.] Anche iniziare l'inverno
non con il frastuono delle bombe,
ma con il nostro cantare, stare lassù.
[A.DE.] Il silenzio, piuttosto
che il frastuono delle bombe.
Ma anche questa questa linea di confine
per noi era molto importante,
perché era dietro casa, e anche
in questi tempi in cui i confini
sono purtroppo luoghi
di conflitto e punti caldi,
questo è un messaggio forte per noi:
poterci dedicare non solo a ciò
che ci piace fare, ma anche a vivere
e vedere come queste attività sportive
possano portare a migliorare, a crescere
anche nella vita quotidiana
e a credere in quello che fai.
Cosa dici, abbiamo ancora tempo?
Abbiamo parlato abbastanza?
[A.H.] Abbiamo preparato un piccolo video.
[A.DE.] Abbiamo ancora tempo
per farvi vedere delle immagini:
questa passione per la fotografia
che abbiamo si è evoluta di pari passo
con la volontà di raccontare
e di condividere le varie esperienze,
e quindi il nostro saluto
e vi ringraziamo per l'attenzione
che ci avete dato fino ad adesso
e vi lasciamo con questo video
che in due minuti cercherà
di raccogliere e di trasmettere
anche a voi, in questo bellissimo teatro,
quell'atmosfera che c'era
qualche mese fa sul Monte Piana.
Grazie mille.
(Applausi)